息が白い
吐くたびに目の前に浮かび上がり
またそっと仕様に消えるほどを踏みしめる
たびにサクッという音がし
ブーツかほんの少し
地面に沈んでしまう
4と鼻は痛いほど冷たいが回路と共に
ポケットに突っ込んでいるてを温かいって
言っ口の細いストラップが肩に食い込む
プライ雲がぼんやりと月をを威嚇していて
星がほとんど見えない
それなのに私は時折星を見ようと空をが
多くその度に行きが1枚かをおうち
思わず目をつぶる
夜の国いいがのすべてが白いとはいえ道に
届く月光が弱く芸者の白塗りみたいな純白
ではない
雨に濡れた髪のような濁った白だよ
突然の風に私はマフラーに顔を埋めその
まましばらく足を進めていく
こんばんは
ふと顔を上げると
お道の先には中学生ぐらいに見える
金髪の外国人症状が立っている隣にはその
子より good 背丈の高い雪だるま腕
が抜く顔には口らしきものしかない
こんばんは足を止めずに返事をする私少女
は雪だるまの顔に何か黒いものを埋め込み
また声をかけてくる寒いね
うんと頷き
進み続ける乳白色の肌をした少女
色あせたワンピースしか来ていないが特に
寒そうではない
きっと寒さに慣れている北欧人だ私は自分
に言い聞かせる彼女に近づくにつれてその
金髪がどんどん白くなっていくように
見える雪の反射のせいだと私は自分に
生かせる
そして少女の前を通り過ぎようとした時
だったその白く祈祷料の髪と肌に映える
真っ青の目に気づき
反射的に立ち止まった
足音がなくなると道は静まり返った雪は
降り続いていたが一瞬で世界が称された
ようになった
学校からの帰り
私は終わりに変えて思わず
と答え
少女そして雪だるまの横を通り過ぎていく
てつだってくれる
また足を止め
息を吐き出す
太陽が沈んでから時間が経っているせいか
塾の勉強が伸びてしまった生が私はとても
疲れている早く休みたい
早くこたつに入って温かい飲み物飲みたい
一心で2キロ以上歩いているそれ日本のが
ずっと囁いている
早く帰るんだと
それでも私は振り替えと
ありがとう
また雪だるまの顔に何か黒いものを
埋め込む少女その隣まで行くと私は
リュックを下ろしてゆきだるまに
もたせかけるふと目を挙げたとき気がつい
た雪だるまの口が妙に歪んでいる
まだ目も鼻もないけれど雪だるまはなんだ
か
まるで叫んでいるように見える向こうから
枝をとってきてん
少女の白い指が道の反対側を指していた
そこには大きなカラマツが一本立っている
リュックそして雪だるまの口をちらりと見
てから
私はうんと頷き
白く染まった大北に向かって歩き始め
ざくざくざく
冷たい風が吹く
マフラーに息を吐き
回路をギュッと握り締めるとその時
不意に背後に視線を感じる後ろには少女
しかいないが臼井由妃をゆっくりと
踏み潰していくうちに
なぜか彼女の視線じゃないという気がして
きた道を渡りきっ
第僕にゆっくり近づいていくここは雪が
高く積もっている15センチは理想でそれ
に地面が凸凹だバランスを取るために私は
ポケットから手を出す今日も寒くなって
良かったねこれでまだしばらくは持つね
突然声をあげる少女
私が振り返ると掃除が雪であるものかを
見上げているまるで私ではなく雪だるまに
向かって話しているかのように返事をする
べきなのだろうか
と戻っているうちに鼻先に白い息が
浮かび上がり
雪だるまと少女うすらと隠す私は大僕の方
に向きな
寒くなって良かったね
また背後で双樹の声がした
第僕から落ちた沢山の上田ざー
昨日にもと囲むように地面に散らばって
いる
細長いものもあれば短くて太いものもある
か
どれもさらになってみたいの氷で覆われて
いる私は雪だるまの腕になりそうな枝を
探し始める
ゴホンとってきて
思わず振り返った
5本
長いの
長女はまだ雪だるまをじっと見つめている
雪皿も目も鼻もないが
まるで
叫んでいるように見えるどこか
激しい痛みに泣き叫んでいるように見える
私はまた木の方を向く
そして白い地面に絡んでー
足元による1メートルはありそうな絵だ手
と手をのボス氷が予想以上に冷たい
予想以上に早く
指の感覚張ってしまうこれでまだしばらく
はも常枝を拾っていくうちに寒さでシビル
経てば道具のように感じられてくる
右手に3本左手に2分枝をつかむと私は
背筋を伸ばし
少女の方に向かって歩く
そのうちに雪がやんだ
いいなあったんそう言ってしばらく雪
だるまを見つめてから
層状視線をこちらに移すつ
私は彼女の前で立ちともに両手を差し出し
てみせよありがとうん
少女を枝を一本取って行き誰もの周りを
ゆっくりと回り始める
ザク
サックサク
女を雪だるまの作りかけの顔をふと見て
思わず言葉が口をついて出た先に目をつ
と様としたそのときだった
まるで兵士が銃剣で敵を指すかのように
少女はいきなりふとうぇあだを雪である
もの胸に突っ込んだ
停滞もしびれるものと私はものなんだ
雪だるまに抜いたまま次と白い手を
突き出してくる聖者私は言われるがままに
枝を差し出すそれはもう1本手に取ると
想像を持ってゆっくりと意気だラムの森を
守り始めるここ
症状2本目の枝を雪であるもの腹に
突っ込んだその激しい動きを見て私は思わ
ず多く歯を食いしばった次今度は枝を日本
取る少女彼女が再び雪だるまの抜くの
見計らって私は生きだらもにもたせかけた
リュックをちらりと見るそう所は3本目の
枝を雪だるまの背中に4本目を首に
突っ込む4本目が入った瞬間
行き皿も声た
まるで嫌な夢を見ているみたいにパスかに
身震いしたまもなく江戸の周りの雪が
濃く染まり始め等
最後のエラーが私の手から滑り落ちた最後
の1本やってみる
こちらに目を向ける聖者私はまたリュック
に目をやった
それに気付きそう所もリュックを見だ
そしてゆっくりと口角を上げ
また私に視線を戻した力はどうでもよく
なったわたしは逃げようと決めた
けれど足が動いてくれない
創造の芽が私の足を孤立化させている
横罫ない目を離せないひきドラマを叫んで
いる
普通で叫んでいる
ザクと一歩踏み出してくる精舎
気が付くと私は廃炉も雪道の上を疾走して
いた
どれくらい走ったか分からないけれど
いくら走ってどんなに鼓動を早めている
ての魂魄をとうとう海が彫って来なかった
ni